AlAlec Castonguay, Christian
DuDufour, Michel C. Auger.
PePetit tour de table rapide.
JeJe ne sais pas si votre
enentourage...
leles gens pensent que vous avez
dédéjà les résultats. Il doit vs
dedemander, Alec, vraiment, tout
pepeut arriver encore?
- - Oui le commentaire que
j'j'abstiens le plus souvent de
momon entourage c'est qu'est-ce
ququ'il se passe?
OnOn attendait pas ça. La plupat
dedes gens se demandaient au
dédéclenchement de la course
élélectorale, ce qui suivait ça
dedepuis le début cette Azeb ona
lele choix avec le gouvernement
lilibéral minoritaire ou libéral
mamajoritaire, de dans l'air du
tetemps depuis maintenant
plplusieurs jours, la possibilié
d'd'avoir un gouvernement
coconservateur est bien réelle.
LeLes gens demandent qu'est-ce
ququ'ils se passent? Il y a
plplusieurs explications possibs
mamais le résultat est le même
ququ'effectivement, c'était
pipile ou face.
OnOn arrive deux semaines avante
jojour du vote et on a une
inincertitude encore grande.
C'C'était un peu la même chose n
202019. C'était serré aussi alos
onon va avoir une campagne assez
dydynamique je pense.
- - On l'a vu en 2019,1 seul pot
dede pourcentage qui séparait au
prprofit des conservateurs les
lilibéraux et les conservateurs,
ququ'ils ont du pauvre dans les
totous dans l'analyse des
cacampagnes?
- - Il reste deux semaines. Je e
réréalisais pas qu'il restait
auaussi peu de temps mais c'est
coconcise que ce sera un
gogouvernement minoritaire.
LeLes Canadiens auront à choisir
enentre le gouvernement libéral
miminoritaire ou consommateur
miminoritaire et moi ça me fait
pepenser beaucoup, comme bien ds
gegens...
lala question de l'urne, ça ne
sesera pasas avec qui est-ce qun
cocontinue la pandémie?
EsEst-ce qu'on continue avec les
lilibéraux ou est-ce qu'on
enenchaîne avec Erin O'Toole.
CeCe sera en défaveur de Justin
TrTrudeau parce qu'il incarne la
papandémie et je trouve qu'au-dà
dede ce qu'on entend dans les
mémédias il y a une lassitude ts
prprofonde au sein de la
popopulation qui pourrait chang.
EsEst-ce que Erin O'Toole va ête
prpremier ministre? C'est bien
bebeau de dire que on ne peut ps
lele diaboliser, mais là, on se
dedemande ce qu'il a à Saturne
prpremier ministre ou pas?
- - C'est intéressant ce que dit
ChChristian ce qu'elle a pandéme
ququi devait aider le sort des
lilibéraux, dans leur esprit, ds
l'l'esprit de beaucoup de gens u
dédébut quelqu'un qui se dit moi
jeje veux tourner la page, je ne
veveux pas entendre parler, il
popourrait être tenté de tourner
lala page sur Monsieur Trudeau?
- - On voit beaucoup de chiffres
dadans les sondages qui montrent
quque les gens veulent du
chchangement. C'est une des
dodonnées du casse-tête. En même
tetemps monsieur O'Toole
acactuellement est meneur dans s
sosondages mais pas beaucoup.
IlIl donne l'impression depuis e
dédébut de la campagne qu'il jo.
IlIl faut qu'il gagne cette
élélection.
CeCe n'est pas une journée comme
auaujourd'hui qui vont l'aider.
- - C'est juste ce que vous venz
dede dire. On va le voir dans ls
exextraits sur les armes. Il
jojouait pour ne pas perdre. Qud
çaça se corse, il faut qu'il aie
enen l'attaque.
ERERIN O'TOOLE, chef, Parti
coconservateur du Canada
- - Je suis le chef et on va
mamaintenir nos restrictions en
cece qui concerne les armes à f.
EtEt avoir un processus pour
unune revue de notre système
dede classification, d'enlever
lala politique et c'est très
imimportant pour moi d'avoir
unune approche sérieuse, ciblée
susur la sécurité publique et
dede respecter le statu quo
mamaintenant et avoir
unun processus indépendant.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU,
chchef, Parti libéral du Canada
- - Lui, il a fait des promesses
auau lobby des armes à feu pour
sese faire élire, de renverser
cece qu'on a fait pour bannir
leles armes d'assaut.
EtEt là, il s'est fait prendre
jejeudi passé et il doit renverr
dedes décisions qu'il avait pris
etet qu'il a donné dans
sasa plate-forme. Il vient
dede changer sa plate-forme,
sosoi-disant et c'est pas ça
dudu leadership.
- - Michel, je commence avec vos
totour de table.
SuSur les armes, journée je
dedevrais dire, quelques jours
didifficiles pour monsieur
O'O'Toole?
- - Oui mais c'est un piège que
lului-même a fabriqué et il s'et
enenfermé. Quand ils ont fait le
prprogramme conservateur, et n'a
papas passé à l'air du temps. Ls
ararmes à feu actuellement ses
prproblèmes quotidiens. On a vue
ququi s'est passé à Ottawa en fn
dede semaine. Vous êtes à
MoMontréal, c'est encore un
prproblème.
IlIl y a même une augmentation s
crcrimes par arme à feu à Québe.
CeCe n'est quand même pas une ds
plplus grandes villes ou
d'd'habitude via ce problème.
DaDans l'air du temps, il y a ds
gegens qui disent ça va faire. l
y y a une question de sécurité.
MoMonsieur O'Toole arrive à dire
ilil faut respecter les droits s
titireurs sportifs et puis on va
avavoir un comité qui va regardr
lala liste des armes prohibées
popour savoir lesquels on va
reretourner en circulation et
lelesquels on va venir.
CeCe n'est pas la réponse à
lalaquelle les gens s'attendent.
CÇa ouvre la porte à Monsieur
TrTrudeau à parler de leadershi.
C'C'est ça qui risque d'être le
prproblème de monsieur O'Toole
dadans les prochains jours.
- - Il ne faut pas qu'il réécrie
sasa plate-forme tous les jours.
- - Je dirais qu'il faut qu'il
sosoit plus à droite.
C'C'est ça que je réalise.
EnEn français, il est moins à
l'l'aise qu'en anglais mais même
enen anglais, n'est pas capablee
mamanoeuvrer dans ses positionse
ninie pas l'importance du dossi.
IlIl y a un aspect pédagogique.l
n'n'est pas capable. C'est ça qi
meme fâche.
IlIl est confronté à l'instant e
cocomplexe mais n'est pas capabe
dede répondre.
CÇa paraît mal pour quelqu'un
ququ'on regarde en se disant que
cece sera le premier ministre du
CaCanada.
IlIl ne pourrait pas répondre de
fafaçon plus habile?
- - Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cecela. Ces stratégies cousaient
unune incapacité?
- - Je parle tenter de dépassere
popoint où les propositions de
coconservateur ont une importan.
OnOn a dévié la plate-forme
apapprenne deux semaines et demi
apaprès l'avoir présenté les
coconservateurs sur le terrain
rérépète à leurs membres que la
poposition n'a pas changé toujos
lele même pas revenir en arrière
susur les hommes d'assaut. Erin
O'O'Toole dit qu'il va garder ls
ininterdictions jusqu'à une
rérévision de la loi. Je pourras
pepermettre certaines armes.
LeLe problème Erin O'Toole rendu
auau quatrième et cinquième jou,
c'c'est un problème de sincérit.
IlIl est prêt à dire une chose n
frfrançais au Québec parce qu'il
sasait que au Québec on a eu
popolytechnique.
EsEst-ce que les candidats sur e
teterrain qui dit vrai? Est-ce
ququ'on n'a pas à s'inquiéter?
AÀ un moment donné, quand la
crcrédibilité du chef commence à
êêtre touchée et qu'on aspire à
dedevenir premier ministre, on
enentre dans une complication ps
mamal plus difficile en campagne
élélectorale.
AuAu-delà de la sincérité, est-e
ququ'il a la force?
EsEst-ce qu'il a la stature et a
foforce?
- - C'est intéressant parce que
ceces questions-là...
- - ça me fait penser Patrice àa
cacampagne de Joe Clark,
miminoritaire. C'est exactemente
gegenre de questions composées.e
slslogan des délits libéraux çaa
êêtre un leader.
IlIl est indécis.
- - Monsieur Clark a duré combin
dede temps Michel?
- - Neuf mois.
- - Moi j'en connais...
c'c'est l'autre sujet.
OnOn ne peut pas prédire le
rérésultat. Ça pourrait être
mamajoritaire. Mais ça va être
l'l'autre sujet abordé. Si on ne
veveut pas d'élections aux 18
momois, ça va être une question
susur l'acte collectif qui nous
enentraîne vers des élections
peperpétuelles?
- - Perpétuelles écoutées, à
totoutes les 18 mois....
cece n'est pas très long. Il y a
ququand même un intérêt.
JeJe ne prends pas position mais
sisinon SI on a un gouvernement
lilibéral minoritaire préparant
sasauter les Canadiens...
ilil a déclenché les élections
sasans raison.
OnOn le reconduit minoritaire,
mamais on n'a pas été assez
imimpressionné par O'Toole.
DaDans 18 mois, je n'ai pas de
prproblème avec ça.
- - OK.
J'J'ai raté mon commentaire là-
dedessus.
CeCe n'est pas nous qui décidon.
JeJe vous fais entendre la
ququestion des manifestants ant-
vavaccs.
JeJe vous fais entendre les ches
susur la question de sécurité ds
évévénements et du discours.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU,
chchef, Parti libéral du Canada
- - C'est désolant de voir
cecette minorité frustrée,
ceces gens marginalisés,
cecette petite fraction
dede notre population qui ne crt
papas dans la science.
M Menacer de nous ramener
enen arrière. Et c'est encore ps
dédésolant de voir qu'Erin O'Toe
dodoit leur laisser de la place.
ERERIN O'TOOLE, chef, Parti
coconservateur du Canada
- - J'aimerais voir une campagne
susur les idées, le harcèlement
dedes candidats de n'importe qul
paparti sont inacceptables.
J'J'aimerais voir des débats
sesensibles sans
leles manifestations,
sasans le harcèlement.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - Chaque parti, chaque chef
dede parti, chaque candidat
dedes partis s'expriment, les gs
écécoutent, font un choix, vote.
DoDonc n'importe quoi qui empêce
unun chef de s'exprimer, je
lele dénonce. Et encore plus
sisi c'est agressif,
enencore plus si c'est violent.
JAJAGMEET SINGH, chef,
NoNouveau Parti démocratique
- - Oui, on a reçu des menaces,
onon continue de recevoir
dedes menaces et c'est
unun problème, je n'ai pas
d'd'inquiétudes, mais j'ai
dedes inquiétudes pour mon équi,
j'j'ai mon inquiétude pour
leles gens qui travaillent avec
nonous. J'ai des inquiétudes por
memes bénévoles.
V Vous pouvais manifester, vous
dedevez, c'est votre droit, mais
vovous ne pouvez pas menacer
leles gens avec des propos
hahaineux, violents,
raracistes, misogynes.
PaParce que les manifestations,
cocomme on a vu, il y a un mélae
dede colère disons il y a des
prpropos dans certains cas
raracistes, il y a des AP c'estn
prproblème récurrent des candids
raravivés qui se font dessiner
totoutes sortes de choses. Est-e
ququ'on exagère le climat?
- - Bien je pense qu'il y a un
clclimat inquiétant.
CÇa ressemble peu ou est-ce que
onon voit aux États-Unis.
LeLes chefs des partis démocrats
etet républicains ne peuvent pas
fafaire de bain de foule parce e
c'c'est trop risqué. La sécurité
esest omniprésente.
LeLes contacts avec les gens sot
didiminués.
MMême chose pour les sénateurs.
JeJe trouve que ça se rassemblat
avavec les voisins américains.
PoPour les chefs, je pense que
JuJustin Trudeau est capable de
vivivre avec des manifestations
mmêmes assez hostiles sur son
paparcours. Ce que je trouve
dodommage, c'est que ça intimide
ququi veulent se rassembler.
LeLes gens ont été appelés à une
teterrasse, les gens ont voulu
vovoir des candidats.
Des s familles veulent entendree
ququ'elle sera dire et puis là
vovous avez une horde de
mamanifestants qui scandent des
ininjures.
C'C'est antidémocratique.
OnOn franchit un pas qu'on n'avt
papas franchi au Canada dans les
dedernières années.
- - Michel C.
- - L'ancien greffier du conseil
prprivé... j'oublie j'oublie son
nonom.
IlIl a dit qu'il avait peur que
ququelqu'un se fasse tuer durant
unune campagne électorale.
BeBeaucoup de gens ont réfléchià
cecela.
L'L'atmosphère n'est pas bonne u
Canada pour les débats
popolitiquques.
CÇa peut exacerber.
CeCela dit, il ne faut pas que
JuJustin Trudeau ne peut pas
exexagérer.
CÇa, c'est allé trop loin. On ne
pepeut pas imputer ces
mamanifestations, même si on a u
dedes militants conservateurs ds
lala foule, on ne peut pas impur
ceces manifestations parties
coconservateur.
LeLe premier ministre, ça vient
avavec le terrain et un
paparatonnerre lorsqu'il y a des
prproblèmes. Évidemment, il y a
dedes gens qui sont très tannés
avavec la pandémie. Il n'écoute
papas toujours la science.
C'C'est sûr que ça se manifesten
cacampagne électorale mais je ne
crcroyais pas que ce serait ausi
viviolent et aussi dur.
- - Oui, on a fait un petit... x
popop sur l'avenue Mont-Royal.
OnOn n'en parle souvent à
l'l'émission. Les gens que
j'j'ai rencontré étais pour.
JeJe me suis fait envoyer des gs
papar des personnes anti-vaccs.
- - Il y a un américanisation de
nonotre culture politique à
didifférents niveaux et au niveu
dede l'agressivité. Si on ajoute
leles réseaux sociaux...
PiPierre-Elliott Trudeau avait
rereçu des bouteilles de bière
lolors de manifestations en 196.
CeCe n'est pas la première fois
ququand même.
PaPauline Marois a été victime
d'd'un attentat.
L'L'extrait que Monsieur Trudeau
esest... je trouve que ce n'est
papas correct que le premier
miministre soit agressif à ce
popoint-là à l'égard des opposas
etet à l'égard des gens qui ne
sosont pas vaccinés. Autant il
fafaut le dire qu'il faut que on
sese fasse vacciné, je trouve qe
MoMonsieur Trudeau diabolise trp
leles gens qui ne se font pas
vavaccinés. Je trouve que ce n't
papas correct.
D'D'autant plus que le climat et
totoxique à la base.
LeLes militants politiques
irirakiennes. Je trouve que cet
exextrait est troublant.
LeLe premier ministre n'est pasà
popour dire des choses comme ça.
- - Vous dîtes qu'il souligne tp
àà - le refus d'une portion de a
popopulation.
- - Il en fait des ennemis et ce
n'n'est pas correct.
- - En même temps les médecins
didisent... il faut les
coconvaincre.
- - Vous parlez de paratonnerre,
c'c'est moi qui va se transformr
enen paratonnerre. L'orage se
trtransmet comme à Ottaw